my siblings and I grew up on our
great-grandfather's farm in California
it was a landscape of our family and our
home when it was clear that nobody in
our generation wanted to take on the
heavy burden of ranching the ranch was
sold to a neighbor the anchor of our
lives was cut and we felt adrift in the
absence of that land for the first time
I came to understand that something
valuable can be best understood not by
its presence but by its absence it was
impossible to know then just how
powerful the absence of those things we
loved would have an impact far into my
future for 23 years my working life was
with Yvonne Jannard I started when he
was designing and manufacturing
technical rock and ice climbing
equipment and a tin shed near the
railroad tracks in Ventura
and when Yvonne decided to start making
clothes for climbers and called this
business Patagonia I became one of the
first six employees later becoming CEO
and helping build a company we're
creating the best products and doing
good by the world was more than just a
tagline Doug Tompkins who would become
my husband years later was an old friend
and climbing companion of Yvonne's and
also an entrepreneur he co-founded the
North Face and Asprey company all three
of these businesses were created by
people who had grown up through the 60s
shaped by the civil rights anti-war
feminist and peace movements and those
values were picked up in those years and
carried throughout the values of these
companies by the end of the 1980s Doug
decided to leave business altogether and
commit the last third of his life to
what he called pain as rent for living
on the planet
at nearly the same time when I hit 40 I
was ready to do something completely new
with my life the day after retiring from
the Patagonia company I flew 6,000 miles
to Patagonia the place and joined Doug
as he started what was the first
conservation project of that third of
his life there we were refugees from the
corporate world holed up in a cabin on
the coast in southern Chile surrounded
by primeval rainforest where a larsa
trees can live for thousands of years we
were in the middle of a great wilderness
that forms one of the only two gaps in
the pan-american highway between
Fairbanks Alaska and Cape Horn a radical
change to our daily lives spurred on as
we had begun to recognize how beauty and
diversity were being destroyed pretty
much everywhere the last wild protected
it places on earth were still wild
mostly because the relentless front
lines of development simply hadn't
arrived there yet Doug and I were in one
of the most remote parts on earth and
still around the edges of Pauline Park
our first conservation effort industrial
aquaculture was growing like a
malignancy before too long other threats
arrived to the patagonia region gold
mining dam projects on pristine rivers
another growing conflicts the vibration
of stampeding economic growth worldwide
could be heard even in the highest
latitudes of the southern cone I know
that progress is viewed generally in
very positive terms as some sort of
hopeful evolution but from where we said
we saw the dark side of industrial
growth and when industrial worldviews
are applied to natural systems that
support all life we begin to treat the
earth as a factory that produces all the
things that we think we need as we're
all painfully aware
the consequences of that worldview are
destructive to human welfare our climate
systems and to wildlife Doug called it
the price of progress that's how we saw
things and we wanted to be a part of the
resistance pushing up against all of
those trends the idea of buying private
land and then donating it to create
national parks isn't really new anyone
who's ever enjoyed the views of Teton
National Park in Wyoming are camped in
Acadia National Park in Maine has
benefited from this big idea through our
Family Foundation we began to acquire
wildlife habitat in Chile and Argentina
being believers in conservation biology
we were going for big wild and connected
areas that were pristine in some cases
and others that would need time to heal
that needed to be re wild eventually we
bought more than 2 million acres from
willing sellers assembling them into
privately managed protected areas while
building park infrastructure as
campgrounds and trails for future use by
the general public all were welcome our
goal was to donate all of this land in
the form of new national parks you might
describe this as a kind of capitalist
jujitsu move we deployed private wealth
from our business lives and deployed it
to protect nature from be devoured by
the hand of the global economy it
sounded good but in the early 90s in
Chile where wild lands philanthropy
which is what we called it was
completely unknown we faced tremendous
suspicion and from many quarters
downright hostility over time largely by
doing what we said we were doing we
began to win people over over the last
27 years we've permanently protected
nearly
fifteen million acres of temperate
rainforest Patagonian steppe grasslands
coastal areas freshwater wetlands and
created 13 new national parks all
comprised of our land donations and
federal lands adjoining those
territories after Doug's death following
a kayaking accident four years ago the
power of absence hit home again but we
at Tompkins conservation leaned in to
our loss and accelerated our efforts
among them in 2018 creating new marine
national parks covering roughly 25
million acres in the southern Atlantic
Ocean no commercial fishing or
extraction of any kind in 2019 we
finalized the largest private land gift
in history when our last million acres
of conservation land in Chile passed to
the government a public-private
partnership that created five new
national parts and expanded three others
this ended up being an area larger than
Switzerland all of our projects are the
results of partnerships
first and foremost with the governments
of Chile and Argentina and this requires
leadership who understands the value of
protecting the jewels of their countries
not just for today but long into the
future partnerships with like-minded
conservation philanthropists as well
played a role and everything we've done
15 years ago we asked ourselves beyond
protecting landscape what do we really
have to do to create fully functioning
ecosystems and we began to ask ourselves
wherever we were working who's missing
what species had disappeared or whose
numbers were low and fragile we also had
to ask how do we eliminate the very
reason that these species went extinct
in the first place what seems so obvious
now
was a complete thunderbolt for us and it
changed the nature of everything we do
completely unless all the members of the
community are present and flourishing
it's impossible for us to leave behind
fully functioning ecosystems
since then we've successfully
reintroduced several native species to
the even our wetlands giant anteaters
pump us deer peccaries and finally one
of the most difficult the green winged
macaws who've gone missing for over a
hundred years in that ecosystem and
today they're back flying free
dispensing seeds playing out their lives
as they should be the capstone of these
efforts in ivara is to return the apex
carnivores to their rightful place
Jaguars on the land giant otters in the
water several years of trial and error
produced young Cubs who will be released
for the first time in over half a
century into even our wetlands and now
the 1.7 million acre
Avada park will provide enough space for
recovering Jaguar populations with low
risk of conflict with neighboring
ranchers our rewilding projects in Chile
are gaining ground on low numbers of
several key species in the Patagonia
region the well dear that is truly
nearly extinct the lesser reyes
and building the Puma and fox
populations back up you know the power
of the absent can't help us if it just
leads to nostalgia or despair to the
contrary it's only useful if it
motivates us toward working to bring
back what's gone missing of course the
first step in rewilding is to be able to
imagine that it's possible in the first
place
that wildlife abundance recorded in
journals aren't just stories from some
old dusty books can you imagine that do
you believe the world could be more
beautiful more equitable I do because
I've seen it here's an example when we
purchase one of the largest ranches in
Chile in Patagonia in 2004 it looked
like this for a century this land had
been over grazed by livestock
like most grasslands around the world
soil erosion was rampant hundreds of
miles of fencing kept wildlife and its
flow corralled and that was with the
little wildlife that was left the local
mountain lions and foxes had been
persecuted for decades leaving their
numbers very low today those lands are
the seven hundred and sixty three
thousand acre Patagonian National Park
and it looks like this and our sealeo
the former Gaucho whose job was to first
find and kill mountain lions in years
past today is the head tracker for the
parks wildlife team and his story
captures the imagination of people
around the world what is possible I
share these thoughts and images with you
not for self-congratulations
but to make a simple point and propose
an urgent challenge if the question is
survival survival of life's diversity
and human dignity and healthy human
communities then the answer must include
rewilding the earth as much and as
quickly as possible everyone has a role
to play in this
but especially those of us with
privilege with political power wealth
where let's face it for better for worse
that's where the chess game of our
future is played out and this gets to
the core of the question are we prepared
to do what it takes to change the end of
this story
the changes the world is made in the
past few months to stop the spread of
Kovan 19 are so promising to me because
it shows we can join forces under
desperate circumstances what we're going
through now could be a precursor to the
broader potential damage as a result of
the climate crisis but without warning
globally we're learning to work together
in ways we could never have imagined
having watched young people from around
the world rising up and going out into
the streets to remind us of our
culpability and chastising us for our
inaction are the ones who really inspire
me I know you've heard all of this
before but if there was ever a moment to
awaken to the reality that everything is
connected to everything else it's right
now every human life is affected by the
actions of every other human life around
the globe and the fate of humanity is
tied to the health of the planet we have
a common destiny we can flourish or we
can suffer but we're going to be doing
it together so here's the truth we're so
far past the point when individual
action isn't elective in my opinion it's
a moral imperative that every single one
of us steps up to reimagine our place in
the circle of life not in the center but
as part of the whole we need to remember
that what we do reflects who
choose to be let's create a civilization
that honors the intrinsic value of all
life no matter who you are no matter
what you have to work with get out of
bed every single morning and do
something that has nothing to do with
yourself but rather having everything to
do with those things you love with those
things you know to be true be someone
who imagines human progress to be
something that moves us toward wholeness
toward health toward human dignity and
always and forever wild beauty thank you
[Music]